Oh today we're gonna talk about my
favorite channel on all of you YouTube
I'm poppy someone that I like to
consider a good omen listen here dear
friend of mine I'm poppy could I even
say fake a girlfriend I'm poppy I think
yes I'm poppy you may have seen her her
name is poppy she's one of those
channels that are just pretty [ __ ]
weird and I don't think there's a point
of me explaining poppy I think it's best
to just watch colored pencils let's find
out which color is the best color which
pair are twelve colored pencils no which
color is it Oh the best color is yellow
[ __ ] it's right there
it's right there I can't find it I think
she's she's looking for her quality
content what the [ __ ]
hi I'm poppy and today I'm gonna show
you what a dope looks like here's one
now is it a boy or is it a girl
that's a penguin hi it's me poppy I'm so
excited about my new video in this video
I'm gonna talk about how happy I am
happy are you wait is that fast track
Oracle delivery oh I better click on
that whoa
I'm boring you're boring
everybody's boring I'm thankful for my
friends family in this photograph of me
so [ __ ] creepy and weird what the
[ __ ] is this it fits I like to hula
I'm Michael joy stop it
get some help will you come to Japan
with me I've lit what if I told you I
was in Japan then I would be like you
went to Japan without me what the [ __ ]
papi not cool
[Music]
why is it funny it's not it's not funny
one thing that I notice is that if you
if you literally add rap music to any
and mute papi
it just works perfectly works perfectly
I'm papi I'm papi I'm papi papi
I'm pop hi I'm poppy I'm poppy I'm poppy
I'm poppy I'm poppy I'm poppy
I'm poppy I'm poppy oh ha ha
Oh poppy I'm poppy
I'm poppy I'm poppy this is dog
I like my dog dogs are my favorite
animals because I can wipe my butthole
if you think about it but holes are just
like belly buttons but on your butthole
I'm poppy but I can be anything you want
if this video gets half a million likes
I will I will send my nudes to keemstar
but if you change your man on the puppy
paw it's a puppy
[Music]